Про плацкартні вагони в Україні ходять легенди.
Вони нерідко стають об’єктом скарг та жартів українців у соцмережах
Але при цьому подобаються іноземцям
Моя перша година в плацкарті
Плацкарт навіть дуже класний.
Дуже комунальний. Соціальний
Саме від цього соціального транспорту
можуть повністю відмовитися в Україні
під час реформи Укрзалізниці
Щоправда, статися це може, за підрахунками міністра інфраструктури Володимира Омеляна
не раніше, ніж за 5 років
Тим часом, експерти до таких ініціатив
доволі скептичні
Плацкарти в Україні -
популярний і доступний для багатьох транспорт
Квитки у таких вагонах коштують значно дешевше, ніж у купейних
і саме через низьку ціну пасажири
часто готові терпіти усі їхні незручності
Відтак повністю відмовитися
від плацкартів навряд чи вийде
принаймні, допоки рівень добробуту українців залишатиметься низьким, наголошують експерти
Теоретично їх могли б замінити
Хюндаями або Шкодами
про наміри повністю відмовитися від нічних поїздів на користь швидкісних
в українському уряді зокрема
заявляли ще шість років тому
Але знову ж таки
ціни на квитки у них значно вищі
і дозволити собі поїздки в таких потягах можуть далеко не всі українці
Вирішення проблеми оглядачі бачать
або у поступовому придбанні
нових пасажирських вагонів,
або ж модернізації старих
Щоправда, і те, і те - обійдеться недешево
Зокрема, один новий вагон коштує близько мільйона доларів
тоді як оновлення старого - вдвічі дешевше
Відповідно, аби модернізувати увесь парк плацкартних вагонів
за підрахунками експертів, знадобиться близько 600 мільйонів доларів
Загалом в Україні 1200 плацкартних вагонів
близько 90 відсотків з них
були випущені ще до 91-го року
Їх поступово модернізують, але відбувається це вкрай повільно
і не скрізь, де це потрібно
Приміром, на початку року в Укрзалізниці обіцяли встановити вакуумні туалети
та кондиціонери у близько ста плацкартних вагонах
щоправда, йшлося лише про відносно нові